star defenseman and cancer survivor  vegas goldeneye shay theodore he's a fan  favorite  and yesterday he launched a new effort  to raise awareness in the fight against  cancer  theodore himself beat cancer last year  but he did lose his grandmother to  breast cancer beforehand  he's now launching a new initiative in  her honor it's called k's  power play the goal is to raise  awareness and provide  means for those who need a mammogram  especially people that don't have  insurance  means a lot to you know myself my family  and  you know the legacy that my grandmother  wanted to leave so  you know it's a special thing and  hopefully can help a lot of people  we have more information about that  program at eight newsnow dot com